how does it feel to be a disney princess
can we say you're a disney princess
i think you can
super cool title even cooler stories
thank you what appealed to you about uh
taking on this this horror role in an
anthology series
mainly the idea of sort of exploring
privilege and jealousy and envy all
these things that i think are
really prevalent in our culture that are
sort of perpetuated by
capitalist society that tells us what
type of person we need to be
um but yeah that's what i wanted to
explore and i
i read it and it felt like visceral to
me i have to imagine how
bizarre and surreal it is to even just
in a role
to put on a wedding dress and run around
it was
so cool also to be in the forest
in a wedding dress is like a very
different thing um
my friends and i were actually i have
this play reading group this is such a
non-sequitur story but you're hearing it
i was playing reading group and we were
talking about like going to a thrift
store and getting like old wedding
dresses and then like going to a park
and having wine
like that's something that we want to do
yes
people will be like you guys are crazy
we don't care um
but yeah it was it was a really cool
experience it felt like
it felt like really wrestling with where
is where does desperation
take you as a human you know um
and yeah to sort of like let
all of those emotions just be in my body
as i'm running through the forest and
like dirtying this like incredibly
beautiful dress
um it was really messy and cool
and just it it felt like a heightened
version of reality like i think we've
all
i think we've all probably had
experiences where we feel like doing
something like that but we don't
actually do it
um to do it do you mean run through the
forest in a wedding dress
doesn't everybody want to run through
the forest in a wedding dress yes
yes put on taylor swift's folklore and
just run through this
wedding dress
i don't want to give too much away but
your character plays this really cool
line of like
i can't tell if she's good or if she's
bad
it almost is really fun because in those
moments a lot of the times
she doesn't know if she's good or bad
like she doesn't know what she's gonna
do next you know and i think that
is very
true to life like what makes a good
person makes a bad person a lot of times
there is not a a easy answer it's not
just
this person's bad person because they
did this one thing most of the time it's
oh we're not actually aware of the
context in which this person performs
this act and there's all of these other
all of these other aspects and all these
other factors that are uh
not being considered are there bad
people and are there good people or are
there only good people that do bad
things sometimes or are there bad people
that do good things sometimes like i
all of these questions were things that
i was wrestling with as i was as i was
playing this character and it was really
fun and also scary that's so interesting
because i think that's something that
i've been thinking about a lot lately
you know when someone
blows something up on twitter or
whatever if somebody something that
somebody did it's like oh are they
inherently a bad person though just
because they made this misstep or a
mistake or
action very interesting yeah it's so
hard
cancel culture is what it's called right
yeah
yeah it's hard and it's that balance of
like you know we do
want to call people out when something
is problematic
but at the same time does that mean they
don't get to exist in the world anymore
and it's i don't think there is one
right answer i think it's a nuanced
case-by-case thing you know um yeah
i feel like the more you have friends in
your life who are willing
to just have hard conversations with you
the better
it is there are so many things that
we're all blind to you know
not trying to be but we just aren't no
you're so right you're so right so you
like straight up quit social media best
decision ever what do you think
best decision ever i
yeah i mean i think that you know it's a
different decision for everyone
and i think that people should do what
they think is right for them i also
think that
i it was the best thing i ever did i
don't know
i i don't um it's funny
it feels like some people are still
shocked by it sometimes i'm like no it
i just did what was best for me
yeah why is that so shocking
yeah i feel great about it you've done a
lot of voice roles recently and it was
announced you're taking over the role of
raya and ryan the last dragon
yeah um i want to ask you i mean first
of all how does it feel to be
a disney princess can we say you're a
disney princess
i think you can um
crazy you were there
that night when last jedi came out and i
was so overwhelmed by emotion
um that i didn't understand it i'm
having a very similar experience with
ryan last dragon if that makes sense
yeah i don't understand
why or how i
got to be involved in these things like
i don't
get it like i you know i've always
wanted to be a performer i've always
wanted to tell stories but um
i feel like the things that i've been
able to do thus far
say a lot more about the people around
me than me if that makes sense like
raya and working with um
carlos and don and all these incredible
people
and also having jamie roberts who cast
that movie and who believed in me more
than i did and probably still does
like i i have not grasped that
yet it feels very very unreal and
doesn't make sense
and i am so excited for people to see it
where are you at with her have you
started doing the voicing are you kind
of in like a
learning about her research phase so we
did we've been basically doing
a lot of the voice over throughout
quarantine
so i don't i can't even count how many
times
i've been um i've recorded for it but i
think it's
pretty much done um
yeah and it's such a beautiful movie
um the writing is incredible i and
obviously the animation is incredible
and
the story itself i think is is really
really powerful
yeah well congratulations i'm so happy
about that thank you so much
it is spooky season which is my favorite
season are you
are you a spooky girl what does your
ideal like halloween
look like beyond watching monster land
oh my gosh i want to show you my
apartment but it like i'm going to mess
up this whole setup
i have a fully oh i'll show you a
picture of my value yeah show me
decorated
my apartment because it's halloween
spooky season
this is my mantle place i don't know
what this is you know those places that
um
have fake fireplaces that's what this is
but look it's spooky
oh my god i love that that's so great
yeah so i love i mean i love halloween i
love
like so basic about those pumpkin
candles i'm like yeah whip them out it's
september 30th it's time for the pumpkin
candles to come out
um yeah and i always watch a bunch of
classics and by classics i mean movies
that aren't actually scary
but are halloween themed like
halloweentown and hocus pocus
yes that's my vibe